integrales y funciones primitivas en qué
situaciones de la vida las aplicamos
veamos el siguiente ejemplo imagina que
vas en bici y te mueves a una
aceleración de 2 metros sobre segundo al
cuadrado durante 10 segundos supongamos
que queremos saber a qué velocidad vas y
qué distancia has recorrido cuando un
cuerpo tiene una aceleración constante
diferente de cero su velocidad aumenta
linealmente respecto al tiempo si
gráfica mos la aceleración de dos metros
por segundo al cuadrado en un plano
quedaría así una línea recta constante
el eje fx es la aceleración y el eje x
es el tiempo sabemos que la aceleración
es el cambio de velocidad sobre el
tiempo y los expresamos como a es igual
a v sobre t donde v es la velocidad y t
el tiempo
ahora para obtener la velocidad de un
cuerpo uniformemente acelerado es decir
que su aceleración siempre es la misma
debemos integrar la aceleración con
respecto al tiempo entonces quedaría v
es igual a la integración de aceleración
por distancia por tiempo y esto es igual
a la aceleración por tiempo más ce que
es la constante la constante se
representa la velocidad inicial con la
que se mueve la bici como se parte del
reposo se tiene un valor de 0 así
nuestra nueva expresión quedaría
velocidad es igual a aceleración por
tiempo como queremos saber la velocidad
final de la bici esto es al término de
los 10 segundos basta con sustituir en
la expresión los datos que conocemos en
aceleración colocamos 2 metros sobre
segundo al cuadrado y en tiempo 10
segundos al multiplicar 2 por 10
obtenemos que la velocidad al término de
los 10 segundos es igual a 20 metros
sobre segundo al cuadrado siguiendo este
mismo procedimiento puede saber el valor
de la velocidad para cada instante de
tiempo
reemplazando t por el valor deseado en
segundos como se verá si gráfica mos la
velocidad vamos a descubrirlo en el
plano tenemos que el eje fx es la
velocidad y el eje x representa el
tiempo la siguiente tabla nos ayudará a
hacer la gráfica en el eje del tiempo
tenemos cero y para velocidad también la
siguiente coordenada es 12 para la
tercera tenemos 2 4 y seguimos con 6,12
por ultimo 10,20 graphic hemos al unir
los puntos fíjate como la gráfica nos
permite conocer la velocidad a la que
vas en bici en cualquier momento observa
muy bien que parte de cero que es el
reposo por ejemplo tenemos que cuando el
tiempo es 2
la velocidad es 4 metros sobre segundo
cuando el tiempo es 6 la velocidad de 12
metros sobre segundo y como ya habíamos
mencionado cuando el tiempo es 10 la
velocidad es 20 metros sobre segundo por
último únicamente nos faltaría calcular
la distancia
recorrido para esto vamos a realizar la
integral de la expresión de velocidad
que habíamos obtenido entonces lo que
tenemos que hacer es sustituir los datos
que tenemos en la fórmula integrada y
así sabremos la distancia final
recorrida al cabo de los 10 segundos
tenemos que la aceleración es 2 metros
sobre segundo al cuadrado y el tiempo es
10 segundos al realizar la operación
obtenemos que 10 segundos al cuadrado es
100 al multiplicarlo por 2 metros sobre
segundo al cuadrado
el resultado es 200 metros y al
multiplicarlo por un medio es igual a
100 metros eso quiere decir que la
distancia recorrida son 100 metros vamos
a graficar lo para ver cómo queda en
nuestro eje de las ordenadas tendremos
la distancia recorrida y como puedes
observar va de 20 en 20
el eje x o el de las abscisas es el
tiempo y el intervalo que tenemos es de
dos en dos
entonces graphic hemos la distancia
recorrida contra el tiempo sustituyendo
los valores de 0 a 10 segundos cuando
haya pasado un segundo la distancia
recorrida será 1 metro para 2 segundos 4
metros para 3 segundos 9 cuando hayan
pasado 4 segundos
habrás recorrido 16 metros en 5 segundos
25 en seis segundos 36 en 7 49 en 8 64
en 9 81 y por último en 10 segundos 100
metros ya sólo nos queda unir los puntos
para ver qué líneas de forma
este solo fue un ejemplo para saber en
qué situaciones aplicamos la integral
pero hay muchos más en todas las
ciencias no dejes de descubrirlo